WESLEY CHUN: Hi, developers,
and welcome to "Serverless
Migration Station," where we
show you one serverless compute
modernization technique.
I'm Wesley from Google,
joined by Martin
and our friend Porter
here to discuss
how and when you would
move an App Engine
app to Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds great.
But what I want to
know is why we'd
want to migrate an App Engine
app to Cloud Functions.
WESLEY CHUN: Very
fair of you to ask,
because you want to know
whether it's worth doing.
One key reason is that
you didn't have much code
to begin with, but App Engine
was all we had available.
Other reasons include less
configuration, more robust
local development
experience, and the ability
to do event-based
background processing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
I didn't even know you could
do this with Cloud Functions.
But isn't the App Engine really
different from Cloud Functions?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, it
seems that way, doesn't it?
App Engine is great
for full-stack web apps
or mobile backends,
while Cloud Function
sounds like it's for
event-driven microservices
or one-off utility
functions, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that's exactly right, Wes.
So I suppose answering when
you'd move from App Engine
to Cloud Functions is the
first order of business
before discussing how to do it.
WESLEY CHUN: Absolutely.
Any time you're considering
switching products,
you don't do it lightly.
I already mentioned
some of the benefits
you get with Cloud Functions.
But, for something
more specific,
I'd say we take a
quick step back.
There was a time
not too long ago
when App Engine was the
only serverless platform
available so you'd use it
for everything, including
small, single-functionality
apps, if you call them that.
Short apps with not much code
are perfect for this migration.
Cloud Functions has
much less overhead,
meaning you can drop app.yaml
and other configuration
files, keeping just
your app files along
with third-party
package dependencies.
Oh, and one other thing.
Cloud Functions does
not support Python 2,
so this is a great chance
to upgrade to Python 3.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah,
that makes sense.
A small app like that is really
just a single microservice,
perfect for Cloud Functions.
Cool.
So what was the other
situation for considering
moving from App Engine
to Cloud Functions?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, you said
the magic word, Martin--
microservice.
In this other scenario, you have
a huge, monolithic app made up
of mostly independent
routes which
could be almost a
collection of API endpoints.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so you
mean I can split out my user
authentication code and
admin-only utilities
to be separate functions,
away from the main app?
WESLEY CHUN: That's
right, especially
if you have different
developers doing
the auth code, the database
code, the admin code, and so
on.
Your dev team won't be
stepping on each other's shoes.
Breaking up that app
into multiple independent
microservices, like
what you suggested,
is a prime candidate to
move to Cloud Functions.
Better yet, if you make
them plug and play,
you can reuse those pieces
for other apps, saving time
and improve maintainability.
It's a valuable refactor
in many respects.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
But what if my monolithic
application is huge
and I have a ton
of microservices?
Would that still be a good
use case for Cloud Functions?
WESLEY CHUN: It's a
good question, Martin.
The general rule of thumb
for using Cloud Functions
is when you have a few or
a handful of microservices.
If you've got many
more than that,
or there are even
dependencies between them,
you may want to consider
keeping it running as-is
on App Engine for now or
consider moving to Cloud Run,
especially if your team
has added containerization
as part of your software
development workflow.
MARTIN OMANDER: Makes sense.
And, if that's the case,
we've already made some videos
showing users how to migrate
from App Engine to Cloud Run,
both with and without
Docker, right?
WESLEY CHUN: That's right.
And both of those videos
also come with Codelabs
so you get that
hands-on experience.
The rest of this video will
be for those considering
Cloud Functions instead.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
Can you tell us more
about the app we're
migrating to Cloud Functions?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, the Cloud
NDB sample app from module 2
is a great example for
us to use because it
doesn't rely on any App
Engine-bundled services.
We moved it from App Engine NDB
to Cloud NDB back in module 2.
And since Cloud Functions
only supports Python 3,
we're going to start
with the Module2b folder
and migrate that app
to Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Can you point me to the
repo, as well as the Codelab,
to remind me what we
did back in module 2?
WESLEY CHUN: Sure thing.
Here are the links to
both the starting repo,
as well as the
Codelab, to remind you
of how we got there
from module 1.
If you did module 2 and
ported it to Python 3,
start with your version.
But if you don't have it, clone
the repo or download the ZIP
file and grab it from
the Module2b folder.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
Now I understand that I should
use Cloud Functions when
I have smaller bits of
code, like a utility
function or a microservice,
rather than a full app.
Is there anything else to know
when getting ready to migrate?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
Well, think about this.
If you don't have
a full app, you
won't need a full web
framework, either, right?
Yes, you still have to
get, service, and respond
to requests, but that's it.
You can just write
code and not have
to think about stacks
or frameworks with that.
So let's go to the computer and
move this to Cloud Functions
now.
You know the pattern
by now, right?
Deploy that app one more time to
App Engine to ensure it works.
This way, there's no guessing
if you run into issues
after migrating.
From your Module2b,
run gcloud app deploy
and confirm that your app adds
a new visit and displays the 10
most recent visits, just
like it's always done.
OK.
Just like when we migrated
from App Engine to Cloud Run,
it's a whole new platform.
So I'll make an entire copy
of your module2b folder.
Now let's start cleaning house.
Delete app.yaml, an
App Engine artifact.
The only config file needed is
the package requirements file,
requirements.txt.
Neither that nor the HTML
index file in templates
require editing.
All of the work is in the
main application file.
And when I say work,
it sounds like a lot.
But it's really just
removing or tweaking things.
As mentioned earlier, we
don't need a web framework,
so strip out almost
everything from Flask.
The app still renders
a template of visits,
so we do need to keep that.
Cloud Functions will give us
a Flask request object when
the Cloud Functions is
called, so we don't need
to ask the framework for it.
We removed importing
Flask, so there's
no need to instantiate it.
No, there's no
longer an app object.
If your app is
dependent on it, you
may be better off
staying with App Engine
or containerizing
it for Cloud Run.
No app means we should
remove the route, as well.
While route is an adequate
name for the route
function of an app, this app is
really just a single function--
visit me.
Since it's now a function, let's
give it an appropriate function
name, visitme().
Cloud Functions will call
it directly with that name.
Plus, it's more descriptive.
And boom, that's it.
Your App Engine app is
now a Cloud Function.
Instead of gcloud app deploy,
it's gcloud functions deploy.
But because Cloud
Functions doesn't
have a config file
like app.yaml,
you need to specify
other aspects,
like which runtime,
the trigger type,
whether to allow unauthenticated
traffic, and possibly
what region.
Now as you wrap up, let's chat
about some things that Cloud
Functions can do that
App Engine can't.
One key feature
is that, while you
can develop Cloud Functions
on the command line
like App Engine, you can also
do everything in the browser--
create functions, code them,
deploy them, and test them--
all from the Cloud Console.
Pretty cool, right, Martin?
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
That is really cool.
Sometimes I'm on
the road and really
only have browser access.
It's good to know that
I'll be able to make fixes
from my hotel room if needed.
I think there's another
thing Cloud Functions can do
that App Engine can't, right?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah,
and perhaps this
is a product differentiator.
We know App Engine apps
are HTTP-triggered.
Well, Cloud Function
supports that.
But now we can
execute our function
in the background as part
of an event-driven process.
Cloud Functions can be
triggered if someone uploads
a file to Cloud
Storage, a new message
comes into Cloud
Pub/Sub, someone
logs into Firebase, and so on.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
It's cool that
event-driven means
you can execute different
Cloud Functions as part
of one single workflow.
Now you mentioned we
can develop, deploy,
and test in the browser.
But I'm really an
old-school developer.
What if I want to do everything
here, on my local laptop?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
The Cloud Functions team
has covered here, too.
For local development
and testing,
check out the
Functions Framework,
a set of open-source
libraries letting
you create lightweight
functions that
run in many different
environments,
including Cloud Functions,
locally on your laptop,
like you wanted, Cloud
Run, or other Knative-based
environments.
Check it out with
the links down below.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Cloud Functions is quite
the versatile product.
I'll definitely consider it
for its target use cases.
And now are there any other
migrations that App Engine
developers should consider?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
Most of the videos in
this "Migration Series"
involves migrating off of the
original App Engine-bundled
services, like switching
away from App Engine
NDB to either Cloud
NDB or Cloud Datastore,
and those are covered
in modules 2 and 3.
Those with App
Engine push queues
can migrate those
to Cloud Tasks.
This is covered in
modules 7, 8, and 9.
Modules 12 and 13 cover
moving off of App Engine
memcache to Cloud
Memory Store and Redis.
And we already discussed
containerizing App Engine
apps for Cloud Run
with or without Docker,
and those are featured
in modules 4 and 5.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
So many modules, Wes.
I'm not supposed to do each
module, one after another,
right?
WESLEY CHUN: That's right.
And more of them are coming.
Developers should
look at whichever
modules make the most sense
for their apps and use cases.
We're here whenever you need us.
Thanks for riding
with us on Porter
for all of these different
migration journeys.
This is Wesley from Google Cloud
on behalf of Martin and Porter,
and we hope to see you at
the next "Migration Station"
or on another "Serverless
Expedition" soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]